[Music]
steady losing news that's me
submitted by come to Philadelphia a lot
of people want you guys to come places
have you guys have you guys been to
Philadelphia
yeah we yep at Gino's and Pat's no
that's that's the tourist track no
everyone says is it delicious though I
got out what the cheese was like the og
way it was still yummy which one is the
non racist building
oh is it Pat one of them who says like
you have to order English or something
which Gino's I think Gino's is the
racist one I don't know I don't know but
I like the other one the white building
oh shoot Meek Mill heads to prison to
serve a two to four year send his
despite public outcry what a Meek Mill
dude he got charged for some other
[ __ ] I think is like possession of
some [ __ ] or something like a long
time ago and he's been on probation
I believe don't all rappers belong in
jail perhaps I just know that not common
for what I know not Lupe yeah
not Jay Cole yeah Jay Cole lives in the
ghetto but he doesn't participate in the
criminal he raps with binoculars yeah
Kendrick lammer I've never heard that
before he raps with binocular mike has a
[ __ ] pen and paper and he just looks
when he observes the ghetto he's like
I'm not gonna drive damn it so bathroom
because he's been getting made fun of a
lot too on the Internet
and he's going to jail man is he still
is he still with Nicki Minaj did that
been awhile ago
yeah get like had his ass handed to in
like a lot of battles recently by
joining how can you have a career after
being beat by Drake that's what what I
think is crazy is that like like Drake
even admitted to having a ghostwriter
for his for his like response and he's
still won that's what I'm saying
what is happened to him his ghostwriter
sucked - Jesus you know what the sad
part is it was still better than Meeks
yeah it was pretty good Meeks was like
what are you what is your point you know
what doesn't make sense
Meek originally started out as a battle
rapper so I don't understand how that
worked out battle rap it's all put yeah
yeah so meek like David said he was on
probation because of a 2008 gun and drug
case so he got arrested back there back
then and so she was on probation for
five years and so he recently he's just
been getting arrested over [ __ ] and
so now the judge was like you know why
you keep violating your probation yeah
you need to go to jail for two to four
years and so what he was doing a violate
the probation was back in 2016 he was
placed under a 90 day house arrest for
violating probation probation due to
unapproved travel and then in March he
was charged with a misdemeanor assault
after an altercation with employees at
st. Lou Lewis International Airport the
charges were ended up being dropped
after he agreed to perform community
service so he doesn't auto follow rules
yeah I can write this does whatever he
wants they already tell them hey
unapproved like unapproved travel we
just got to get it approved this next
one is really dumb it's the the one in
August um meek he was charged with
reckless endangerment in New York City
after he was writing his quad on Mike
Manhattan she's like why are you gonna
do this this one goes out of his way
yeah you know Rough Riders I would love
to live a day in his brain though
because how much he breaks the law it's
like you have to put effort into it I
feel like he was like should I ride a
quad through the elementary school or a
horse or a tank yeah and I'm half of
choices for all these and I had to
figure out the best one like he did a
math it's interesting because like the
only reason I found this out was because
I was reading in
about how wrong it is for him to go to
jail over something so arbitrary in the
past but the stupid thing about this is
like there are rules set in place and
you broke them multiple times
yeah but the majority though is what
they're saying is I free Mick Meek Mill
it's not right the system's broken it's
like I mean you don't have to ride a
quad anyway this is this is one of those
things where like yeah like only half
the story comes out and then people hear
what they want to hear exactly so I was
just kind of like I read that article
and then they kind of obviously they
they cherry picked a lot of things out
and they didn't mention anything so I
was like this sounds a little precarious
so I kind of looked up like of course
you know so this was the straw that
broke the camel's back yeah it was the
little thing that was like okay me this
is your 50th defense it broke the
camel's back killed it wrong food you're
the boss yeah but the cameos bag still
know that all right wait so I also I
feel like these people like like when
rappers like they have so much people
saying yesterday I'm or like always
feeling like you know like they're the
[ __ ] you know and then but then the
celebrity bro I feel like he did this
for more street cred cuz he lost all his
battles he's all like you know what I'm
I might not be able to like with my rap
battles but I'm still good though they
don't give a [ __ ] but like Drake is
really gonna be jealous of him like oh
you're right your wit you in a bunch
over you and all your unapproved travels
you're a third would be the third time
in nine years he's going to do and he's
trying to prove to Drake that he's a
thug Drake
not even a thug yeah Jake's like I don't
care takes like Jake's like I'm [ __ ]
from Canada and I see
like I'm not trippin this is not the
[ __ ] I've never been in there but I keep
on watching scared straight and that
does not look fun people looking at you
like you're a sweet little dumpling what
part of you know which prison he's gonna
go through do you know the difference oh
yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure which one
but his lawyer is saying that they're
gonna be appealing that ruling and that
his lawyer was like my goal is to not
get him to serve any time to just bring
him home community service if he has
money you know
yeah jay-z was saying that the sentence
handed down by the judge was just unjust
and Hippo jay-z's on his side to jay-z's
speaking out like a lot of people see
jay-z's artists is that way
jay-z doesn't just speak out for no
reason was he sign to mighty might be I
think honestly even for the judge like
at that point it's just I guess for the
judges to make an example out of him was
like you were not above the [ __ ] law
yeah and a lot of celebrities always
think that they're above the [ __ ] law
dude Obama just went to [ __ ] serve as
a like to serve jury duty
like he's not above it either it's
because he's bored now he's at that
landing he ain't got no presidential
[ __ ] to do he's just on retirement you
know that thinks I would do jury duty
too if I didn't have [ __ ] to do as a
judge snowboard I'd be pretty frustrated
he was like praying for my brother Meek
Mill right now God he prays for
everybody though maybe they know some
sure we don't know maybe oh it's one of
those or it's one of those causes that
if the whole community is behind it's
like I guess I got to get behind it too
it's free so and you know what when
those happen I just disappear from
social media for that day everybody
wanna pray for natural disasters you
won't see me saying [ __ ] wait what is
that no control there's no dream
I know bandwagon or [ __ ] that everyone
want to pray for things and [ __ ] be
sad and [ __ ] I'm gone yeah that's my
thought process feeling like everyone
else do like why don't you why don't you
support Joe why don't you say [ __ ] on
Twitter because I don't [ __ ] care
that's not my reasoning
I'm just like everyone else got it they
don't need it my voice to be added I do
care but same with you I feel like
people are people that that matter
they're saying it exactly thank you guys
matter you some of these kids though
I think the might thing with it is that
people just say things just to say
things so it's like yeah I'll keep you
my prayers if you're not on your [ __ ]
knees over bent over a [ __ ] bed
praying for me [ __ ] don't say it don't
say it you're not praying for me you're
not praying don't say it it's just
become like so casual too and it's
you're praying to it I think it's like a
spiritual and religious thing too so
people even like just watch over it on
that [ __ ] too so light weights a little
that's why people will say thoughts I
think about this terrible tragedy and
that's all they're willing to give
people are actually praying and saying
gee jazz please no but like when people
tweet that right like when they're
saying prayers for like social media
people right after they tweet that [ __ ]
are they really getting on their bed and
say zebra today Jesus I want to prove
quick
yeah or are they even doing something
like um people that like pray for Vegas
did they give blood are they giving
money like or do they just say that it
responsibly without any action see
that's where I feel like that's why I
don't want to say [ __ ] is because if I'm
not gonna do stuff like donating or
doing anything I'm not gonna say [ __ ]
period yeah because I feel so fake I
mean that there's like a lot of Chris's
criticism for like you know activism or
it was a call like oh yeah I get worried
or like there's like faux tests like you
know like people that like just say it
just to be a part of something yeah I
mean I don't even know why active
activism no that's not a fictive ism I
don't even know what black slacktivism
negative ISM I don't know why there's
pressure on everyone on social media to
do the same [ __ ] especially if your
comic because like you'll say some
stupid [ __ ] and it's like why the [ __ ]
do you expect this comic to all of a
sudden be a philanthropist or like so
for example just the other day on my
Twitter I said I will
water bowl of Cal's ass and then after
that I'm supposed to say like oh prayers
going out to these victims prayers to
these like what the [ __ ] like I have a
branding that I need to keep up with
with we're just motorboated cows asses I
have I got to poor things so the first
one is I think you should just obviously
stay true to who you are right so if you
didn't feel like doing it because you
know I mean that's just not genuinely
you then that should be fine and no one
should give you any [ __ ] for it however
they still do but whatever right
opinions are like [ __ ] [ __ ]
everyone has one the second one is if
people are like pray for so-and-so do
this or whatever and they're not doing
it for me I'm like [ __ ] it like again
the universe kind of balances itself out
phonies are discovered but if by the
slim chance that one of you know the
fans is watching it and actually
believes that this person is actually
doing something and then they get
motivated to do something positive it
kind of worked so I just get motivated
to tweet movement you know what I mean
like even if it's fake there's still
positivity that's happening I think I
find it funny though when they're like
when I get it wheat as a how come you
don't post your political views I'm like
political I'm a comedian like I don't
know [ __ ] but why do you why are you
looking for political guidance from
people who don't that's what I'm talking
about like you know what the see so
here's here's here's me III agree with
that too like I sometimes feel that same
way but then when I see like other
idiots that are basically like even
having opinions I'm like well [ __ ] I'm
gonna put my cards on the table like if
because they're the only voice that's
being heard
that's actually what's happening a lot
on social media the dumbest people have
the loudest voices so it's like whoa I
gotta counter that by at least I do feel
that I don't want to participate in this
but like there's so many stupid tweets
that are out there okay chef it's the
kid in the class that's like who knows
the answer I do and then you're like oh
my gosh shut the [ __ ] up not [ __ ]
that guy again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]